[Musique]
c'est dans la ville de Theresa que
jaillir bolsonaro débute sa campagne
express dans la région du nord-est du
Brésil la plus pauvre du pays d'une
importance stratégique
[Musique]
c'est ici qu'il a fait le score le plus
bas au premier tour et n'a remporté
aucun des 9 états de cette immense
région
le Nord-Est est historiquement à qui au
Parti des Travailleurs le parti de Lula
qui a obtenu 67% des voix au premier
tour c'est 13 millions de plus que
l'actuel président ce jour-là les
sympathisants de jaillir bolsonaro sont
venus faire une démonstration de force
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui est un jour historique notre
région Nord-Est a été la plus critiquée
la plus oubliée
nous montrons aujourd'hui que nous
sommes avec bolsonaro et que le futur
est avec lui donc notre vote et notre
droit de réponse
fait tout pour attraper son retard chez
les Brésiliens les plus modestes à
l'aube de l'élection il a augmenté le
montant de l'allocation familiale qu'il
a créé et dont presque la moitié des
bénéficiaires et dans le nord-est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il s'attribue aussi le mérite de la
dérivation du fleuve San Francisco censé
apporter de l'eau à 12 millions de
personnes dans cette région au climat
aride
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
initi en 2007 par Lula qui revendique la
paternité de 86% des travaux le projet
est au cœur de la bataille entre les
deux candidats un héritage que jaillir
bolsonaro essaie de s'attribuer non sans
difficulté car depuis des années il
multiplie les attaques xénophobes contre
les habitants du Nord-Est
un argument utilisé par Lula pour
discréditer jaillir bolsonaro Lula a
gagné dans neuf des dix États qui ont le
plus haut taux d'analphabétisme vous
savez quels sont ces états ceux du
Nord-Est il y a un manque de culture on
voit des jeunes filles enceintes dans le
nord-est là où il y a la location
sociale à la naissance qui tape sur leur
ventre et qui disent celui-ci sera un
frigo celui-ci sera une machine à laver
et qui ne veulent pas travailler
[Applaudissements]
un ores qui ce jour là agressif
acclamant héros Lula l'enfant du pays
les gens pensent que nous les habitants
du Nord-Est nous sommes nés pour être
pauvres pour être un alphabet pour être
des maçons mais non
nous respectons les maçons mais nous
voulons aussi être ingénieurs nous
voulons aussi être médecin nous voulons
aussi être avocat personne ne choisit
d'être pauvre toute sa vie
Lula lui-même est originaire du père
nambouk fils de paysan analphabète
devenu cireur de chaussures puis
syndicalistes métallurgiste son histoire
fait écho chez une grande partie de ces
sympathisants
notre symbole de lutte et de résistance
c'est le camarade qui a vécu nos combats
et nos souffrances il veut que nous nous
en sortions comme lui s'en est sorti
selon une étude de l'institut brésilien
de géographie et de statistiques après
les deux mandats de Lula plus de 25
millions de Brésiliens sont sortis de la
pauvreté le Parti des Travailleurs reste
donc très populaire dans cette région
pauvre
ces logements en périphérie de Theresa
sont le symbole des nombreuses réformes
sociales qui ont vu le jour sous l'ère
Lula
toutes ces maisons font partie du
programme de logements social là dans
ces ensembles d'immeubles les gens ont
ouvert des barres des commerces ça a
changé la vie de tout le monde la vie
d'asselio elle a basculé en 2014 quand
il a reçu les clés de sa maison lui et
sa femme font partie des 15 millions de
Brésiliens défavorisés qui entre 2009 et
2018 ont pu accéder à la propriété grâce
au programme ma maison ma vie
avant on habitait chez mes parents on
avait construit une petite maison dans
le fond du jardin 15 ans à vivre au fond
du jardin jusqu'au jour où on a réussi à
avoir cette maison
c'est un cadeau merveilleux le plus beau
qu'on ait reçu
cette maison c'est notre nid on
l'appelle notre nid
la famille a aussi reçu l'équivalent de
1000 euros pour acheter des meubles et
bénéficier de la location familiale de
Lula à Célio dit tout devoir à
l'ex-président et au Parti des
travailleurs
cette banderole ne sort pas de la
voiture comme on dit ici dans le
nord-est papa Lula avec tout ce qu'il a
fait pour notre région malgré les
efforts de jaillir bolsonaro pour
conquérir le vote du Nord-Est Lula
serait largement en tête dans cette
région selon un récent sondage datafolia
l'ex-président y aurait 70% d'intention
de vote un score tellement haut qui lui
permettrait de remporter cette élection